what will be taking place then in the
coming hours to mark her majesty's death
let's just run through that once again
uh the king and his queen consort
camilla will return to london today from
balmoral with the monarchy to hold his
first audience with uh prime minister
liz trusses outlined there by rhiannon
in central london 96 rounds of gun
salutes will be fired in tribute to the
late monarch and bells will ring out at
westminster abbey simples cathedral and
at windsor castle
both houses of parliament will gather at
noon with liz trust's leading tributes
in the house of commons
well liz trusts and senior ministers
will also attend a public service of
remembrance at saint paul's cathedral in
central london today
and in the evening king charles is
expected to address the nation in a
televised speech where he will pay
tribute to his mother and pledge to
serve as head of
state and tomorrow morning an accession
council will meet at st james's palace
in london to formally proclaim charles
as the new sovereign
then in the afternoon the commons will
hold a sitting to allow senior mps to
take the oath of allegiance to king
charles iii